eu venho aqui falar sobre a educação e
sobre utopias ouvir essa palavra utopia
normalmente nós pensamos para que eu
estou a falar do tupi e estas são coisas
que não conseguimos alcançar então eu
vos mostrar durante o tempo que eu
estiver aqui porque é o tupi é
necessária na nossa educação
em 1981 eu terminei o curso de letras
modernas e eu pensava que eu ia ser
tradutora que eu ia viajar o mundo
inteiro a produzir as línguas mas quando
terminei essa altura em que o estado
moçambicano nos deixava escolher o
emprego que nós criamos eu fui colocada
na escola secundária como professora de
português e eu não gostava nem um pouco
então eu não queria ser professora e eu
fiquei um ano dois anos no terceiro ano
que eu era professora foi transferida
para shay eu julgo que foi ali que eu
comecei a gostar de ensinar porque eu
enfim enfrentei mas a realidade é que eu
não conhecia aqui em maputo
eu comecei a dar aulas em escolas pobres
os meninos sentados no chão eu não tinha
se cortarei nem cadeira também não
tínhamos livros escolares
eu tinha que inventar os próprios
materiais para ensinar e foi um choque
para mim comparar os alunos de maputo
onde de chave mas foi bom porque eu acho
que aí aconteceu uma coisa me que foi
tocar a minha sensibilidade e ver que eu
estava num espaço em que era necessário
eu olhar para aquelas crianças de fazer
alguma coisa por elas eu fui continuando
meu percurso passando por vários cursos
linguística mas não me sentia bem na
linguística também porque era muita
teoria e eu não sabia o que eu ia fazer
com que os conhecimentos
aí eu vejo não a minha missão aqui é dar
aulas e ensinar eu vou fazer o curso de
educação e de psicologia da educação
terminando o curso eu trabalho na
universidade pedagógica formar
hoje nós tínhamos aquela modelo de
primeiro teoria depois prática o que
acontece é que a nossa teoria até hoje
continua é toda importada
eu sou professora didática os livros de
didática todos para situações ideais
turmas de 20 alunos turmas pequenas com
materiais didáticos a realidade que nós
tínhamos de que nossa equipe nós os meus
alunos falavam todos os dias ela acolhe
a professora
o que nós estamos a aprender aqui na
universidade
nós não sabemos muito bem o que é que
nós vamos fazer com toda esta teoria
lá na escola e aí eu e vários colegas
começamos a pensar nós temos de romper
essa forma de fumar professor já que
moçambique e todos unidos decidimos nós
vamos sair dessa torta marfim que é
universidade
nós temos toda hora falar que os alunos
têm problemas do fracasso escolar no
ensino superior porque foi mal preparado
da ascom da área da primária e nós
resolvemos vamos mudar
infamous para as escolas secundárias
vamos para as escolas primárias e foi eu
diria sim uma autêntica revolução na
universidade que era macho que está a
acontecer
como é que o doutor quer ir pra escola
primária o que vão lá fazer e nós fomos
nós vamos à procura de outros saber
porque nós achávamos que o nosso futuro
o professor tinha de ser filmado na
realidade moçambicana e aí eu julgo que
começa uma outra visão m que é chegar à
escola primária encontrar uma situação
completamente precária estou a falar na
cidade de maputo escolas sem água
meninas sentadas no chão sem material
didático os professores estou a falar
nas crianças nos alunos os professores
desmotivados neste momento nós falamos
muito no absentismo dos
as pessoas falta as pessoas estão
desinteressados os pais não participam
nas reuniões e aí eu começo a fazer
pesquisa e havia quem são estas crianças
recolher o que elas produziam e vocês
podem olhar pra ele ver aquela é uma
composição sobre a família de um aluno
da 6ª classe junto letras mas nós
consegue entender o que eu tenho a dizer
o que eu quero escrever e quando nós
chegávamos perto dela e os meus
estudantes praticantes lê octo
escreveste elia
mas lia aquilo que eu queria dizer não
aquilo que eu tinha escrito que eu
comece a pensar não
nós temos de ter uma saída
nós temos de procurar um caminho
qualquer eu gosto daquela fórmula na que
é a droga benefício já ter conseguido
encontrar um equilíbrio na vida uma luz
no fundo do túnel que nos conduza a uma
educação melhor porque para mim sem
educação não há crescimento nenhum
normalmente os economistas
deus fala muito em crescimento econômico
anos desenvolvemos sabe que vamos
crescer economicamente mas sem educação
não é possível eu posso dizer que
durante o meu percurso eu juntei me a
outras
eu tenho mais geramos mais professoras
no no centro de moçambique em quelimane
porque nós criamos mudar a educação
moçambicana
formamos uma cooperativa de ensino
formamos uma escola que hoje têm muito
sucesso mas eu não estava satisfeita
porque porque nós estávamos a atuar numa
minoria nós temos de pensar numa
educação moçambicana que não é só aquela
que nós estamos no nível privado
nós temos de olhar a maioria porque a
maioria sobretudo no ensino público que
está até sexta classe sem conseguir
escrever
e aí vem pra mim uma coisa que eu acho
que é fundamental
tal na educação que é a questão ética
que o compromisso ético quando nós
falamos de ética nós estamos a falar de
vida e eu costumo muito pensar nos
médicos
o médico quando tem um paciente um
doente eu fico com a qual tenta te curar
aqui 80 o que nós fizemos na educação
todos estes meninos que não escrevem não
é nossa responsabilidade e para mim o
crescimento econômico o desenvolvimento
da indústria
o desenvolvimento da ge indústria
falamos muito a extração de recursos
minerais da agricultura é certa não vai
ser possível e moçambique
se nós não pensarmos no desenvolvimento
sócio cultural
mas como educadora a mim interessa
pensar no que é o desenvolvimento
individual que é quem é esta pessoa e eu
estou a usar de propósito esta palavra
pessoa não aluno não professor não
gestor
quem é que lhe indivíduo como é que nós
vamos conseguir alcançar um crescimento
econômico para todo o país
se nós deixarmos estas crianças sem
aprender
elas terminam o ensino básico tranquila
porque temos promoção à semi automática
mas elas não estão qualificadas porque
não têm os conhecimentos
então é necessário que nós pensemos
neste crescimento individual na educação
um crescimento entre doc tem a ver com a
parte cognitiva normalmente nós
pensarmos na momento na educação mas
também física mas também emocional e
também espiritual
então aí eu vou pensar e durante estes
últimos anos eu tenho pensado numa
proposta para a educação moçambicano
tanto para a escola pública esta aqui eu
me referi está com problemas de vária
ordem de infra-estruturas de material
didático de professores desanimado
desmotivado
mas eu também quero pensar na escola
privada porque a minha surpresa com as
com as escolas privadas que eu conheço é
que elas têm elas têm carteiras nem
livros os meninos levam lancha tem
uniforme tem tudo mas o que eu noto
também a faltar alguma coisa
mesmo nestas escolas por isso pra mim
essa proposta de educação acolhedora
eu não eu vou dizer para todas as
escolas mesmo para o ensino superior e
sua professora do ensino superior nós
lidamos com adultos e nós pensamos o que
estudar acolher o adulto o produto já
está formado
ela não precisa de carinho não precisa
de acolhimento acolherá na eu coloco
aquelas mãos ele porque a colher quer
dizer receber outro aceitar o outro
taliqua lelé se ele é portador de
necessidades educativas especiais nós
temos trabalhar com ela assim se ela é
magra ser curtos e baixos e negros e
brancos
nós temos de acolher aceitar as
dificuldades que este aluno tem e
procurarmos então saídas e pensarmos
esta educação acolhedora é uma utopia e
eu coloco ali pra mim aquela é imagem
melhor imagem do utopia de sonho
porque se nós queremos um crescimento em
moçambique nós queremos desenvolvimento
nós precisamos de novas do piso para nos
agarrar mas já qualquer coisa porque o
sonho que move o homem porque neste
momento nós estamos numa situação de
muita turbulência na educação
só que essa turbulência não pode
continuar
ela tem de ser modificado nós temos de
ter um sentido
por isso eu falo e utopia possível
porque é necessário é necessário mudar
as coisas porque eu trago essa proposta
de educação acolhedora a partir da minha
própria experiência
porém se eu penso que é possível é
possível porque eu própria
eu estudei no colégio de freira juntos
colégio
mais caros do clima os meus pais pagaram
primeira e segunda classe
depois não conseguia mais pagar
mensalidade e até a 5ª classe até
terminar a quarta classe eu tinha todo o
ensino de bola com todas as condições e
as freiras já colheram por isso eu falei
acolher dar todas as condições eu tenho
essa experiência muito boa teve uma
outra experiência felicidade de ter
estudado no tempo da educação socialista
em que o estado tenha políticas
assistencialistas e eu digo assim eu fui
infeliz artha eu nunca paguei nadar na
escola
sou da geração do centro 8 de março
nós chegávamos o estado dava roupa
comida transporte no meu ano da fifa em
tudo para nós estudarmos o que é que nós
tínhamos de fazer exercício físico
corretja e estudar e fazer uma coisa que
é muito importante na educação não só
ficar com teoria como também ter a
prática
então existem determinadas condições que
nós temos e teremos sabe que para nós
termos essa educação acolhedora e claro
que eu estou a falar em utopia eu estou
a falar em sonho mas eu estou a falar
num sonho realizável aqui e moçambique
eu trago algumas imagens de escolas
públicas nos âmbitos anos tem este
cenário mal de algumas escolas públicas
mas tem um cenário bom também escolas
moçambicanas públicas e comunitárias em
que nós vemos uma escola construída com
limpeza com cores para ensinar os
números por exemplo eu já passei durante
todos estes anos todos a fazer pesquisa
em várias partes do sangue de sula norte
centro oeste sete propriedades para
pesquisa educacional que eu faço e eu
encontrei escolas públicas
cuidados com materiais locais se vocês
virem ali
o muro é de caniço os baloiços todos
construídos com elementos locais uma
educação acolhedora ela precisa de
elementos que muitas vezes as nossas
escolas nós esquecemos
nós ficamos só ensinar matemática
geografia história etc
esqueci esquecemo-nos 200 elemento
artístico porque o ser humano também se
alimenta de arte e com materiais locais
nós podemos produzir essa arte
estas esta escola pública que eu estou a
dizer que está com problemas e nós
costumamos dizer assim educação
quando nós modificamos no ensino
quando nós matriculados na escola
crianças adolescente e adultos de
classes sociais desfavorecidos
nós temos de fornecer comida também em
moçambique já teve seus países ganhar um
monte de vocês que estão aqui nesta sala
recorda do tempo da arom fada e do conto
de lei
e então o que é educação acolhedora é
uma educação pra mim que junta dois
elementos que na educação não somos
americana agora estou a falar pro mundo
inteiro nós disse anos nós separamos
porque nós achamos que a escola é lugar
de razão é lugar de ciência é lugar de
técnica vamos ter conhecimentos
científicos
então nós queremos todas muito muito
atenta para beber todos os conhecimentos
que está a receber
esquecemo nos do lado emocional
como é que nós esquecemos disto por
exemplo se nós vamos explicar os
fenômenos da natureza
se nós estamos explicar por exemplo que
existem planetas do solo da lua exceto
eu digo assim nosso ensino muitas vezes
é um ensino sem sabor nenhum porque
estamos a falar de planetas
estamos a falar da lua mas nós não
trazemos a dimensão estética que é
necessária por exemplo a lua
a lua aqui no sangue ela tem um
significado cultural muito grande
é por isso que existe o tratamento da
lua para as crianças
quando nós falamos da lua a lua sempre
em todas as épocas
ela levou o ser humano a fantasiar
porquê porque existem esses outros
elementos de emoção que nós não
conseguimos trazer no nosso ensino
sempre
então para mim é uma educação acolhedora
que possa proporcionar um
desenvolvimento maior para moçambique e
um crescimento também maior para os
amigos
pensamos num crescimento coletivo este
crescimento coletivo nós fizemos assim
nós queremos que o sangue seja um país
desenvolvido
nós queremos com o sanbs saia do
sub-desenvolvimento não pode sair se nós
não olharmos o indivíduo
aquilo só que os dados que nós temos nas
nossas salas
começando pelo momento o corpo não sei
normalmente no ensino nós olhamos a
cabeça dos estudantes
vamos olhar o corpo por isso é que não
podemos naturalizar situações como falta
de carteiras
o corpo é importante eu falo muitas
vezes disso porque para escrita para
leitura eu preciso ter uma carteira pra
sentar eu tenho de ter uma determinada
postura
a escrita é uma habilidade que eu quero
é o desenvolvimento psicomotor
motricidade fina do braço
eu tenho de ter apoio para poder
escrever
nós estamos em áfrica nós estamos em
moçambique
nós temos de olhar com muito cuidado a
questão do espírito as nossas meninas
estão a desmaiar na escola escola não
sabe responder esta dimensão espiritual
em áfrica não pode ser descurada
e para além disso eu já disse a educação
ela tem de ser feita também com beleza
as nossas escolas são escolas tristes
pintadas de cor castanha
se secas são castanhos os cinzentos não
tem um elemento qualquer de cor não
motiva não estimula crianças
temos trazer beleza temos trazer amor
temos trazer emoção e eu julgo que
apenas uma educação acolhedora que tenha
em conta estes elementos que eu
apresentei hora
conduzimos saber que para um
desenvolvimento maior
eu quero terminar apenas dizendo assim
moçambique tem de se desenvolver
olhando para a maioria ea maioria não
está a ser devidamente cuidada
temos escolas privadas boas não duvido
disso mas não é esta minoria que pode
pra frente sozinho
temos de olhar a todos ter um
crescimento individual e sim que nos vai
conduzir a um crescimento coletivo maior
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]